there was one time when I got to fight
with Eddie Guerrero he had a tag match
and we went out there we got heat on
Eddie we beat him up I didn't touch
Eddie I actually worked on Chavo
Guerrero they beat up Eddie pretty badly
you go back to the gorilla where Vince
McMahon is and they're watching the show
and Eddie comes back and he's flipping
out he's going crazy what the effort you
guys punching me and hit me and you're
not taking care of me and I said Eddie I
didn't do it he said you did do it I
said I didn't do it Ed he pushed me and
I pushed him back and he shoots a double
leg on me and I was like oh that was a
mistake
so I sprled and got him in a front
faceold and I started choking him out
that should have never happened I should
have just taken the blame and said hey
you're right my guys were tough on you
instead I showed a lot of Pride I didn't
want him to think that I was responsible
for the guys that that beat him up
probably a half hour later someone says
hey why would you shoot a double egg on
Kurt Angle he said cuz I'm [__]
stupid